you know I think leftists want Biden
because they actually agree with me and
what I said was in 2019 2020 if you
think Donald Trump really is going to
destroy this country and destroy our
democracy and you're a leftist he's your
guy yeah because you vote for Joe Biden
and you are empowering the banksters the
corporations and you are giving them
their strangle hold on this but if you
vote for Donald Trump he'll give you
everything you think is coming
destruction here's the truth they do
agree with me in essence but not on who
is going to cause the destruction they
actually agree with me wholeheartedly
Joe Biden is and US Joe Biden will
destroy the country Donald Trump will
fix the country they do want Joe Biden
to destroy the country so they vote for
Joe Biden if they if they if they
actually thought Trump was that bad
they'd vote for him yeah but the truth
is they know Donald Trump will make
America great again secure the borders
bring back jobs they don't want that
they want Biden's Alzheimer's
ises catastrophe War conflict crisis
they want to be a they want to see the
United States fall apart and and it
makes a lot of sense from the
perspective of the left Empower uh why
you know you wonder why it is the
leftists are supporting the FBI the FBI
is going after Trump supporters that's
perfect one I I've been saying this
consistently uh uh the win condition for
the left is the start of a civil war not
winning a civil war they they want the
system to shatter in half and that gives
them basically it throws the whole
machine into disrup and then they can
start doing whatever they want imagine
Chaz chop but with no federal Authority
at all nothing to it's already bad
enough there's barely any Chaz like uh
the Chaz Garden that's right well then
everyone will definitely starve to death
yeah but I but it's it's we can make fun
of these people for their inability to
actually Farm in any capacity but think
about what that means it means roving
bands of communist barbarians raiding
pantries and Farms because they don't
want to starve to death and they're
dangerous violent extremists so if the
country actually you know if Texas kicks
off into some kind of you know fed
versus State dispute and then you know
Trump has already called on states to
deploy their National Guard several
already have I think 10 different states
have sent law enforcement or National
Guard let's say the conflict actually
breaks off we don't call it a Civil War
for the time being but then Joe Biden
makes a move to try and suspend like oh
you know Florida has been supplying Aid
to Texas in this conflict so they send
feds down to Florida to try and then
then state troopers in Florida are
fighting with FEDS and now we're like
holy crap this has begun these Chaz chop
people are going to be like now's our
chance and they're going to immediately
be like the feds can't stop us local
government can't stop us and the reality
is I think if you look at who's more
organized I would argue
that in the event something like that
happens the far-left will be more
organized than law enforcement the
reason
is the the the anti faels are in loose
communication with each other but they
have no external threat Factor if the
federal government gets into it with
Texas and it's like it's very light I
don't know if this this will actually
escalate the border patrol is already
sided with Texas National Guard we'll
see where that goes but let's say the
conflict between the feds and this and
and Texas escalates into several other
states it's like a Mexican standoff the
feds are way too uh preoccupied are not
going to be able to muster up any kind
of forces to stop farle farle extremists
from seizing territory in major cities
and local police cut off from the feds
are going to just ditch they're going to
back I'm out we remember what happened
when the far leftists went to the police
station in Minnesota in Minneapolis what
happened all the cops ran full speed out
of the building they were not organized
in the way people think they are the
far-left is or at least willing to do
crazy things so that's what I kind of
see happening I don't know well at least
in the case with Texas I think it's more
likely to be protracted litigation than
any uh than anything else and for
political reasons alone I personally
think this is just my opinion we'll see
if you agree with this I think the Biden
Administration is going to Blink I think
that when they see half the states in
the United States are on paper against
them when they see that the vast
majority of the population including
most independent voters are completely
against them with regards to the Border
crisis eventually it'll become
politically too tenuous for Joe Biden to
maintain his position he's either going
to do a 180 or he's going to get crushed
politically and then and then the most
likely outcome is that the left tries to
take a shot at Trump or something like
that unfortunately unless they false
flag something possible so it depends on
what you think how desperate you think
the feds are and how depraved they are
right now the challenge is if Joe Biden
like the border patrol saying no we
agree with Texas on this one we're not
going to we're not going to be arresting
them or stopping them from securing the
Border I mean that's that's showing the
emperor has no closeth Joe Biden has no
command over his law enforcement agents
they win the Supreme Court ruling on the
ability to tear down these barricades
and border patrol just out the union
outright said nah how desperate will the
federal government be to assert their
Authority Federal Supremacy they may not
care that much Biden may just be
feckless and go you know and just
disappear but that creates another big
risk or maybe not maybe it's their wi
condition uh showing that states now
have Supremacy in the law over the
federal government because of what Texas
did other states are going to follow
suit it's uh it's blood in the water the
Sharks will come but they've already
been doing so I mean a handful of states
and and cities as have been openly
ignoring the immigration law anyway the
sanctuary I mean they completely ignored
Trump they wouldn't work with him they
won't work with ice or anything like
that so there's already a precedent of
so basically there nothing new Under the
Sun kind of but but it's an escalation
and a serious one at that it's one thing
when you know what's happening with
Sanctuary states and cities federal
government will say hey we want you to
you know arrest these illegal immigrants
they say we will not cooperate with the
federal authorities but when Ice shows
up they don't stop them ice walks in
makes the arrests and they just say we
won't assist you in any of this so it's
passive resistance they've not actually
confronted imagine if in California when
Ice shows up to deport some illegal
immigrant California National Guard
blocks them from doing so that's where
we're at with Texas so what we've seen
with Sanctuary states and cities so far
has just been passive the Texas move is
active resistance they deployed armed
soldiers if that is the next step and
the bid administration's response is
well gosh darn it whatever other states
are going to be like we our laws matter
more and think about what this means for
Texas Texas allows you to have a
suppressor for your gun so long as it's
bought in Texas and they don't require
you to get the federal registration that
you need to get uh anywhere else which
is in defiance of Federal Regulation
based the NFA yeah so uh the National
Firearms Act and its modifications mean
that if you want to get a suppressor for
your gun you got to fill out this these
crazy Federal forms takes a long time uh
you got to pay $200 I think it takes up
to a year for some people eight months
to a year in Texas they're like no you
can buy one we won't arrest you for it
the feds might get mad about it screw
them already you see the passive
rejection of federal law in Texas and
other states are following suit with gun
sanctuaries I wonder if if the federal
government really does fear that this is
one grain of sand too many actively
resisting with armed soldiers and they
decide they do want to play hard ball
it's not going be border patrol agents
walking up and being like well you know
we got to do what we got to do it's
going to be a false flag it's going to
be a scop it's going to be it's going to
be real war and I love this when the
media says conspiracies aren't real and
they say oh conspiracy theory it's like
if you think governments are are
declaring it's it's like the colonial
era Warfare of people marching down the
fields pointing guns at each other
you're you're a and of course the
media wants people to believe that but
real war is going to be the bid
Administration saying I don't care how
suppress Texas let's figure that out out
and that would be false flag we got you
got a convoy heading down to the border
right now you got a bunch of private
militia people saying they're going down
to the border and all it takes is one
fed to show up we're a magae I think I
tend to agree with you that I think the
Biden Administration will blink and I
think what's interesting is that they
are already trying to spin the narrative
as fast as they can so when mayor
released this letter today saying you
know I'm not going to appear in front of
the house um Homeland Security you guys
made it difficult I mean it's a long
letter where he's saying you guys made
it difficult to schedule and then you
asked for written testimony and actually
I'm really good at my job and actually
we've deported tons of people more
people than Trump has ever deported and
you know he is desperately trying to
make the case that he is both good at
his job and also there's a whole section
where he talks about how he's received
accolades from the Biden Administration
he's gotten he's been uh rewarded for
his service and so in some ways it has
made me wonder if mayorcas knows on some
level that Biden could potentially ask
for his resignation as a way to say like
look I'm compromising you with you
Republicans I'll get rid of the DHS
secretary and then you guys have to come
to the table when it comes to
Congressional nominations because that's
what they're saying right now they're
saying actually the only way to change
the Border situation they being you know
Democrats sort of left leaning
politicians the only way to change the
situation at the border is in Congress
and actually the Biden Administration
can't do anything and this is where I
start to think that the Biden
Administration knows they're on the
losing end of this and they are likely
to try and spin or back out of the
position they put themselves
the funny part is that the thing that
might stop a potential false flag in a
greater border crisis would be Biden's
ego because again he does the strongman
thing he in his mind because he's a
little bit scrambled he's still 30 40
years old he's still beating up corn
poop and stuff like that and so to save
his lagging presidency and really
genuinely try to get another term he
might slip his handlers he might fire
mayorcas uh he may not he may reprimand
him or something like that he could do a
total 180 we've seen this on energy uh
one day he's approving new drilling
leases the next day he's canceling a
pipeline the next day he's okaying more
exports and the next day he's blocking
exports it doesn't even make any sense
that's why I completely incoherent
that's why I was saying I think it's a
little bit of both that there are some
people making independent decisions I I
bet a lot of his staff are going this
guy's out of his mind I'm I'm I'm just
going to go do it I'm going to do
whatever I want the other half are like
I have no idea what he said I'm just
going to do something random and so it's
a mix of incoherence and just people
running running you know their own show
it's a bad sign for a reelection there's
no clear leadership in this white house
and if you look at his record it's
inconsistent across the board on a lot
of things I mean again of course you
know it's easy to make fun of her but
krent janpierre is constantly saying
things that then get immediately just
proven or challenge in the White House
Press press by the White House Press
Corps and so the administration to me
reads as weak I obviously have some of
my own bias because I do a lot of stuff
I wouldn't agree with anyways but their
messaging is constantly trying to spin
and redirect and look the other way and
that to me says that they have no plan
it's very different from the things you
hear coming out of you know not even
just Trump but any you know conservative
leaning politician right now well Karine
Jean Pierre's got her own problems she
rarely knows what she's talking about no
she never knows you you think she must
be angry at a certain point being like
you guys send me out there and I look
stupid every day but she she makes it
clear that she's angry every single day
that's the that's the thing it's wild uh
it doesn't make you miss jump at all
yeah at least that was funny because you
had the circle back around memes yeah
and dressing like what was that
character from peanuts and she always
wore like the the green shirt and stuff
was it was it Peppermint Patty maybe the
Tomboy chick with the green shirt and
stuff and Andi always yeah and Jen saki
always looked like her and acted like
her too I don't know peint Patty I feel
like Jen made a good exit of the
Biden Administration when she did they
were like two years in she was like I'm
going to pass the torch to this you know
young lady of color and I'm going to go
get my own show and I'm going to leave
this shipwreck behind she was good at
her job she she made a great decision
she did best decision of her life as
much as people were like I can't stand
her she's lying I'm like yeah yeah but
she she was that's also her job to lie
oh of course to spin but she was good at
it we we just know she's lying and the
Press they're morons and they they they
buy into it Kar Johan Pierre is just
like one of the stupidest people just in
general and it's just it's it's amazing
how every day there's some kind of
scandle where she says something
moronic and just the whole the white
house looks
ridiculous there I don't blame her for
all of it Biden is ridiculous you know
but she makes Biden look coherent
sometimes that's the whole problem I
mean look at Kamala Harris too it's like
a it's a barrel of monkeys may could you
imagine like what if what if Kamala
Harris is this super intelligent
articulate witty fast talker and and
what happens is her handlers come to her
and say you will not upstage the
president is that clear and she's like
what is that supposed to mean I mean how
am I supposed to articulate my thoughts
in public and explain this to the people
in a way that's that's manageable if I
have to talk like I'm stupider than Joe
Biden figure it out she's like oh my God
she goes home to her husband and she's
like they're threatening me that if I
don't that if I make Joe Biden look
stupid I'm in trouble and the next day
she walks out in stage to give her
speech she goes Community is our
community and that's the story of how I
imagine herself practicing in the mirror
every morning and the second gentleman
is like you're doing great just let us
keep the cool house demeaning title
second gentleman I don't really like
that so funny dude she could also be a
method actor like George dub playing Dum
that's possible too i' I've always
thought that George W was actually very
cunning and he realized that he could
get away with a lot more if he played
the befuddled like slightly hazy
slightly older dude and then
Dick Cheney takes the rap because Dick
Cheney's there behind the
curtain rubbing his hands together boms
yeah we're going to kill the children
and then her daughter was going like I I
look up to you Daddy and he's like
that's right I mean granted she was an
old woman when he was president but
still uh I I think Kam is much you know
what I really can't stand is the people
who assume all these people are stupid
MH when they're like the leftist will
say Donald Trump's a he's so
stupid I watched some ad some guy made
against Donald Trump and they're like
his bankruptcies should have ended his
business
but his bank buddies bailed him out I'm
like Donald Trump had 500 businesses and
five of them had bankruptcies and they
weren't even his Core Business the Trump
uh the Trump organization was doing fine
and generating a ton of money if you
think Joe Biden is stupid you are
incorrect he may be incoherent old with
a broken brain by today by today that's
fair that's fair I don't think KLA
Harris is stupid I think she's probably
doing what you're describing making
herself look as dumb as possible for
some reason that benefits are you don't
get to position by being stupid there
there there are people who who want to
believe and it's I think it's more of a
leftist idea that people in positions of
power and wealth are undeserving of
their power and wealth and it may be
undeserving is an opinion depends on
what you mean by undeserving but they
typically are saying like this guy did
nothing to to get where he is Donald
Trump's so stupid his dad gave him the
money no Trump did get money from his
dad but he still had to build all of
this there are a lot of people who
inherited money who went nowhere and
fizzled out people uh who work hard are
smart enough and and have the Merit or
are evil enough are going to get ahead K
Harris sounds really dumb when she gives
speeches but I don't believe for a
second that she's that stupid exactly
yeah I don't think she is necessarily
stupid I think she is somewhat
self-absorbed right like I don't think
she genuinely entered politics you know
to serve the people not that very many
do although I think there are some who
think maybe in the beginning they can
help uh I think ultimately she saw being
Biden's VP as the chance to springboard
her potential Run for the presidency and
she was never able to pull favorably
enough I mean her likeability was always
low even lower than Biden's I you know
Biden got to hang out with Obama for a
couple years people had a somewhat
friendly uh view of him but she just
became worse and worse and worse she was
almost a surprising VP pick to me
because you know other than maybe the
demographic demographic position she
holds her personality just never
resonated with anyone at all thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net